Hilary Clinton just won't go away and
staffers at Vanity Fair have some
suggestions to keep her busy and out of
politics it's time to start working on
your sequel to your book what happened
what the hell happened get someone near
Texas to disable autofill on your iPhone
so that typing and s doesn't become form
exploratory committee for 2020 take up a
new hobby in the new year volunteer work
knitting improv comedy literally
anything that'll keep you from running
again to finally put away your james
comey voodoo doll now we all know you
think that James Comey cost you the
election and he might have but so did a
handful of other things it's a year
later and time to move on so cheers to
you Hillary Clinton cheers to you
Hillary literally anything please those
New Year's tips were Hillary didn't go
over well with some of her supporters
and there's been backlash on social
media over the video so I'm calling it
sexist particularly she suggests Hillary
take up a hobby like knitting the
staffer who made that comment says they
did snarky New Year's resolutions for a
bunch of politicians including President
Trump and a spokeswoman for Vanity Fair
was contrite saying it was an attempt at
humor and we regret that it missed the
mark
Tom shaloo our resident knitter not
sexist they did you know that she had a
number of suggestions
she said knitting which is I guess it's
associated with women I'm not a sexist
so I don't know he also suggested she
take up comedy an art form associated
with men so I think look I said
yesterday on the show Kennedy did I not
say they are saying lock her up now the
Democrats are chanting at about Hillary
Clinton they all want her to go away did
you see those people could you see more
typical Democrat support they're not
these are Millennials this is a change
in of the media guard and these are
people saying please whatever you do
don't run again yes we're tanking the
party and so I am absolutely and this is
something that I've been saying for some
time that Hillary Clinton is so
desperate and embarrassing and lack such
self-awareness that she needs to go
weigh and re-examine her life in private
but now I am saying after such a
glorious year of making fun of her she
is such a great time I hope she didn't
go anywhere I hope she starts running
for president in 2018 because she
provides so much material Hilary please
wherever you are stay in the limelight
you are a blast it is it is an endless
supply of jokes and barbs so stick with
a kiss I think the saddest part of the
story is that Vanity Fair somewhat
apologized you know we were talking
before about the cocoons that people in
the Internet era are able to keep for
themselves
it's a thermostatically-controlled 72
degrees everything everything everything
affirms your world view everything
reinforces what you think and you only
hear that you're right
the fact that this mild lampooning of by
the way we should point out the most
disastrous most disastrous national
politician to presidential elections
lost to the two most unlikely lost twice
once to a guy once to a guy whose middle
name was Hussein and the other time she
lost she lost she's the worst Democratic
nominee since at least at least Dukakis
he beat Rick Lazio don't you forget it
it's true she beat Rick Lazio so she so
here is this person obviously a target
for ridicule rightly a target for
ridicule in this case it's gentle
mocking its light its gentle mockery and
the fact that that is too much that this
is just too hot a dose we just can't
possibly take this mocking and a test
and we have to dissect it on the basis
of is knitting sexes you do something
wrong or someone calls you on something
that person is not automatically racist
or sexist right your input on this
twenty eight explosive shot that and I
never ever have to talk about Hillary
Clinton it's frustrating but by the
Democrats but also because she's not the
future of the party and if Republicans
who love making fun of her
and you know a republican and democrat
never they're talking about her go into
2018 thinking we're gonna relitigate
2016 they're gonna be in for a big
surprise come November because there are
a lot of New Democrats who are not
Hillary Clinton emma-crats they're
raising money they're fired up and so
while this is funny we're about to turn
the page into a big election that is not
gonna be about the Clintons but though
and there will be some new names and new
faces that we could talk about and I'm
going to talk about tonight ideas a not
political failure oh speaking of a whole
[Laughter]